You're using Pydantic and it seems pretty straightforward, right?
But could you adopt some simple changes to your code that would make it a lot faster and more efficient?
Chances are you'll find a couple of the tips from Sidney Runkel that will do just that.
Join us to talk about Pydantic performance tips here on Talk Python.
Episode 466 recorded June 13th, 2024.
[music]
Welcome to Talk Python to Me, a weekly podcast on Python.
This is your host, Michael Kennedy.
Follow me on Mastodon, where I'm @mkennedy, and follow the podcast using @talkpython,
both on fosstodon.org.
Keep up with the show and listen to over seven years of past episodes at talkpython.fm.
We've started streaming most of our episodes live on YouTube.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel over at talkpython.fm/youtube
to get notified about upcoming shows and be part of that episode.
This episode is brought to you by Sentry.
Don't let those errors go unnoticed.
Use Sentry like we do here at Talk Python.
Sign up at talkpython.fm/sentry.
And it's brought to you by Code Comments, an original podcast from Red Hat.
This podcast covers stories from technologists who've been through tough tech transitions
and share how their teams survived the journey.
Episodes are available everywhere you listen to your podcast and at talkpython.fm/code-comments.
Hey, folks, I got something pretty excellent for you.
PyCharm Professional for six months for free.
Over at Talk Python, we partnered with the JetBrains team to get all of our registered users
free access to PyCharm Pro for six months.
All you have to do is take one of our courses.
That's it.
However, do note that this is not valid for renewals over at JetBrains.
Only new users there.
And if you're not currently a registered user at Talk Python, well, no problem.
This offer comes with all of our courses.
So even if you just sign up for one of our free courses at talkpython.fm,
click on Courses in the menu, you're in.
So how do you redeem it?
Once you have an account over at Talk Python,
then it's super easy.
Just visit your account page on Talk Python Training.
And in the Details tab, you'll have a code and a link to redeem your six months of PyCharm Pro.
So why not take a course, even a free one, and get six months free of PyCharm?
Sydney, welcome back to Talk Python.
It's awesome to have you here.
Thank you.
I'm super excited to be here.
And yeah, I'm excited for our chat.
I am too.
We're going to talk about Pydantic, one of my very favorite libraries that just makes working with Python data,
data exchange so, so easy, which is awesome.
And it's really cool that you're on the Pydantic team these days.
More than I guess, you know, let's jump back just a little bit.
A few weeks ago, got to meet up a little bit in Pittsburgh at PyCon.
How was PyCon for you?
It was great.
So it was my first PyCon experience ever.
It was a very, very large conference.
So it was a cool kind of first introductory conference experience.
I had just graduated not even a week before.
So it was a fun way to kind of roll into full-time work and get exposed really to the Python community.
And it was great to just kind of have a mix of getting to give a talk, getting to attend lots of awesome presentations,
and then most of all, just like meeting a bunch of really awesome people in the community.
Yeah.
I always love how many people you get to meet from so many different places and perspectives.
And it just reminds you, the world is really big, but also really small.
You know, get to meet your friends and new people from all over the place.
Definitely.
I was impressed by the number of international attendees.
I didn't really expect that.
It was great.
Yeah.
Same here.
All right.
Well, maybe a quick introduction for yourself for those who didn't hear your previous episode,
and then we'll talk a bit about this PyDantic library.
Yeah, sure.
Sounds great.
So my name is Sydney.
I just graduated from the University of Wisconsin.
Last time I chatted with you, I was still pursuing my degree in computer science.
And working part-time as an intern at the company PyDantic,
which is kind of founded around the same ideas that inspired the open source tool,
and now we're building commercial tools.
And now I've rolled over into full-time work with them, primarily on the open source side.
So yeah, very excited to kind of be contributing to the open source community,
but also getting to help with our commercial tools and development there.
Yeah, yeah.
Awesome.
We'll talk a bit about that later.
Super cool to be able to work on open source as a job, as a proper job, right?
Yeah, it's awesome.
It's really unique.
I've kind of encouraged lots of people to contribute to open source as kind of a jumpstart
into their software development careers, especially like young folks who are looking to get started
with things and maybe don't have an internship or that sort of thing set up yet.
I think it's a really awesome pipeline for like getting exposed to good code and collaborating
with others and that sort of thing.
But it's definitely special to get to do and get paid as well.
Indeed.
So it's a little bit unbelievable to me, but I'm sure that it is true that there are folks
out there listening to the podcast that are like, "Pydantic, maybe I've heard of that.
What is this Pydantic thing?"
Yeah, great question.
What is Pydantic?
So Pydantic is the leading data validation library for Python.
And so Pydantic uses type hints, which are optional in Python, but kind of generally more
and more encouraged to enforce constraints on data and kind of validate data structures,
et cetera.
So we're kind of looking at a very simple example together right now where we're importing
things like date time and tuple types from typing.
And then kind of the core of Pydantic is you define these classes that inherit from this
class called base model that's in Pydantic.
And that inheritance is what ends up helping you use methods to validate data, build JSON
schema, things like that.
And so in our case, we have this delivery class that has a timestamp, which is of type
date time, and then a dimensions tuple, which has two int parts.
And so then when you pass data into this delivery class to create an instance, Pydantic handles
validating that data to make sure that it conforms to those constraints we've specified.
And so it's really a kind of intermediate tool that you can use for deserialization
or loading data and then serialization, dumping data.
Yeah, it's a thing of beauty.
I really love the way that it works.
If you've got JSON data, nested JSON data, right?
If you go to pydantic.dev/opensource, there's an example of here that we're talking about.
It's got a tuple, but the tuple contains integers, two of them.
And so if there's a tuple of three things, it'll give you an error.
If it's a tuple of a date time and an int, it'll give you an error.
Like it reaches all the way inside and, you know, things I guess it compares against.
It's a little bit like data classes.
Have you done much with data classes and compared them?
Yeah, that's a great question.
So we actually offer support for like Pydantic data classes.
So I think data classes kind of took the first step of, you know, really supporting using
type hints for model fields and things like that.
And then Pydantic sort of takes the next jump in terms of like validation and schema support.
And so I think one like very common use cases, if you're defining like API request and response
models, you can imagine like the JSON schema capabilities come in handy there.
And just ensuring like the integrity of your API and the data you're dealing with.
Very helpful in the validation front.
Yeah, yeah.
Very cool.
Okay.
So I guess one more thing for people who are not super familiar that Pydantic is, I think
it's used every now and then.
Let's check it out on GitHub here.
I'm just trying to think of, you know, like some of the main places people have heard
of it.
Obviously, FastAPI, I think is the thing that really launched its popularity in the early
days if I had to guess.
But if we go over to GitHub, GitHub says that for the open source things that Pydantic is
a foundational dependency for 412,644 different projects.
Yeah.
That's unbelievable.
Yeah, it's very exciting.
We just got our May download numbers and heard that we have over 200 million downloads in
May.
So that's both version one and version two.
But definitely exciting to see how kind of critical of a tool it's become for so many
different use cases in Python, which is awesome.
Yeah, absolutely.
It's really, really critical.
And I think we should probably talk a little bit about Pydantic v1, v2 as a way to get
into the architecture conversation.
Right.
That was a big thing I talked to Samuel Colvin maybe a year ago or so, I would imagine.
Think around PyCon.
I think we did actually a PyCon last year as well.
Yeah, for sure.
So a lot of the benefit of using Pydantic is we promise some great performance.
And a lot of those performance gains came during our jump from v1 to v2.
So v1 was written solely in Python.
We had some compiled options, but really it was mostly Pythonic data validation.
Or I say Pythonic.
It's always Pythonic, but data validation done solely in Python.
And the big difference with v2 is that we rewrote kind of the core of our code in Rust.
And so Rust is much faster.
And so depending on what kind of code you're running, v2 can be anywhere from two to 20
times faster in certain cases.
So right now we still have this Python wrapper around everything in v2.
But then, and that's kind of used to define schemas for models and that sort of thing.
And then the actual validation and serialization logic occurs in Pydantic core in Rust.
Right.
So I think the team did a really good job to make this major change, this major rewrite,
and split the whole monolithic thing into a Pydantic core, Pydantic itself, which is
Python based in a way that didn't break too many projects, right?
Yeah, that was the goal.
You know, every now and then there are breaking changes that I think are generally a good
thing for the library moving forward, right?
Like hopefully whenever we make a breaking change, it's because it's leading to a significant
improvement.
So we definitely do our best to avoid breaking changes and certainly someday we'll launch
a v3 and hopefully that'll be an even more seamless transition for v2 users to v3 users.
Yeah, I would imagine that the switch to Rust probably, that big rewrite, it probably caused
a lot of ways, thoughts of reconsidering, how are we doing this?
Or now that it's over in Rust, maybe it doesn't make sense this way or whatever.
Yeah.
So we kind of, you know, we got a lot of feedback and usage of Pydantic v1, so tried to do our
best to incorporate all that feedback into a better v2 version in terms of both APIs
and performance and that sort of thing.
Sure, sure.
John out in the audience asks, how did the team approach thread safety with this?
So Rust can be multiple threads easy.
Python, not so much really, although maybe soon with free threaded Python.
Yeah, that's a good question.
So our kind of Rust guru on the team is David Hewitt, and he's very in the know about all
of the multi-threading and things happening on the Rust side of things.
I myself have some more to learn about that, certainly.
But I think in general, kind of our approach is that Rust is quite type safe, both performant
and type safe, which is great and memory safe as well.
And I think most of our, I'll talk a little bit later about some like parallelization
and vectorization that we're looking at for performance improvements.
But in terms of safety, I think if you have any questions, feel free to open an issue
on the Pydantic core repo and get a conversation going with David Hewitt.
I would imagine it's not, you guys haven't had to do too much with it, just that Python
currently, but soon, but currently doesn't really let you do much true multi-threading
because of the GIL.
But the whole, I think, you know, yeah, I think Python 3.13 is going to be crazy with
free threaded Python and it's going to be interesting to see how that evolves.
Yep.
Yeah.
I know we definitely do some jumping through hoops and just, you know, having to be really
conscious of stuff with the GIL in Pydantic core and Py03.
And Py03 is kind of the library that bridges Python and Rust.
And so it's heavily used in Pydantic core, as you can imagine.
So I'm excited to see what changes might look like there.
Yeah, same.
All right.
Well, let's jump into the performance because you're here to tell us all about Pydantic
performance tips.
And you've got a whole bunch of these.
Did you give this talk at PyCon?
I did partially.
It's a little bit different, but some of the tips are the same.
I don't think the videos are out yet, are they?
As the time of recording on June 13th.
Yeah.
No, I actually checked a couple of minutes ago.
I was like, I said one thing during my talk that I wanted to double check, but the videos
are not out yet.
So.
No, I'm really excited.
There's going to be a bunch.
There was actually a bunch of good talks, including yours and some others I want to
watch, but they're not out yet.
All right.
Let's jump into Pydantic performance.
Where should we start?
I can start on the slideshow if we want.
Yeah, let's do that.
Awesome.
So, yeah, I think kind of the categories of performance tips that we're going to talk
about here kind of have some like fast one liner type performance tips that you can implement
in your own code and then kind of the meat of the like, how do I improve performance
in my in my application that uses Pydantic?
We're going to talk a bit about discriminated unions, also called tagged unions, and then
kind of finally talk about on our end of the development, how are we continuously improving
performance?
You know, Pydantic internals, lies, et cetera.
Sure.
Do you have the equivalent of unit test for performance?
Yeah, we do.
We use a library called CodSpeed that I'm excited to touch on a bit more later.
Yeah.
All right.
Let's talk about that later.
Perfect.
Yeah, sure thing.
So I have this slide up right now just kind of talking about why people use Pydantic.
We've already covered some of these, but just kind of as a general recap, it's powered by
type hints.
And one of our biggest promises is speed.
We also have these other great features like JSON schema compatibility and documentation
comes in particularly handy when we talk about APIs, you know, support for custom validation
and serialization logic.
And then as we saw with the GitHub repository observations, a very robust ecosystem of libraries
and other tools that use and depend on Pydantic that leads to this kind of extensive and large
community, which is really great.
But this all kind of lies on the foundation of like Pydantic is easy to use and it's very
fast.
So let's talk some more about that.
And this, yeah, well, the speed is really interesting in the multiplier that you all
have for basically a huge swath of the Python ecosystem, right?
We just saw the 412,000 things that depend on Pydantic.
Well, a lot of those, their performance depends on Pydantic's performance as well.
Right?
Yeah, certainly.
Yeah, it's nice to have such a large ecosystem of folks to also, you know, contribute to
the library as well, right?
Like, you know, because other people are dependent on our performance, the community definitely
becomes invested in it as well, which is great.
This portion of Talk Python to Me is brought to you by OpenTelemetry support at Sentry.
In the previous two episodes, you heard how we use Sentry's error monitoring at Talk Python,
and how distributed tracing connects errors, performance and slowdowns and more across
services and tiers.
But you may be thinking our company uses OpenTelemetry.
So it doesn't make sense for us to switch to Sentry.
After all, OpenTelemetry is a standard, and you've already adopted it, right?
Well, did you know, with just a couple of lines of code, you can connect OpenTelemetry's
monitoring and reporting to Sentry's backend.
OpenTelemetry does not come with a backend to store your data, analytics on top of that
data, a UI or error monitoring.
And that's exactly what you get when you integrate Sentry with your OpenTelemetry setup.
Don't fly blind, fix and monitor code faster with Sentry.
Integrate your OpenTelemetry systems with Sentry and see what you've been missing.
Create your Sentry account at talkpython.fm/sentry-telemetry.
And when you sign up, use the code TALKPYTHON, all caps, no spaces.
It's good for two free months of Sentry's business plan, which will give you 20 times
as many monthly events as well as other features.
My thanks to Sentry for supporting Talk Python to me.
But yeah, so kind of as that first category, we can chat about some basic performance tips.
And I'll do my best here to kind of describe this generally for listeners who maybe aren't
able to see the screen.
So when you are...
Can we share your slideshow later with the audience?
Can we put it in the show notes?
Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
Okay, so people want to go back and check it out.
But yeah, we'll just, we'll describe it for everyone.
Go ahead.
Yeah.
So when you're validating data in Pydantic, you can either validate Python objects or
like dictionary type data, or you can validate JSON formatted data.
And so one of these kind of like one liner tips that we have is to use our built in model
validate JSON method, instead of calling this our model validate method, and then separately
loading the JSON data with the standard lib JSON package.
And the reason that we recommend that is one of the like crux of the general performance
patterns that we try to follow is not materializing things in Python when we don't have to.
So we've already mentioned that our core is written in Rust, which is much faster than
Python.
And so with our model validate JSON built in method, whenever you pass in that string,
we send it right to Rust.
Whereas if you do the JSON loading by yourself, you're going to like materialize Python object
and then have to send it over.
Right.
And so you're going to be using the built in JSON load S, which will then or load or
whatever, and then it'll pull that in, turn into a Python dictionary, then you take it
and try to convert that back to a Rust data structure, and then validate it in Rust.
That's where all the validation lives anyway.
So just get out of the way, right?
Exactly.
Yep.
It's like skip the Python step if you can, right.
And I will note there is one exception here, which is I mentioned we support custom validation.
If you're using what we call like before and wrap validators that do something in Python,
and then call our internal validation logic, and then maybe even do something after, it's
okay, you can use model validate and the built in JSON dot load S because you're already
kind of guaranteed to be materializing Python objects in that case.
But for the vast majority of cases, it's great to just go with the built in model validate
JSON.
Yeah, that's really good advice.
And they seem kind of equivalent.
But once you know the internals, right, then it's well, maybe it's not exactly.
Yeah.
And I think implementing some of these tips is helpful in that if you understand some
of the kind of like pedantic architectural context, it can also just help you think more
about like, how can I write my pedantic code better?
Absolutely.
So, the next tip I have here, very easy one liner fix, which is when you're using type
adapter, which is this structure you can use to basically validate one type.
So we have base models, which we've chatted about before, which is like if you have a
model with lots of fields, that's kind of the structure you use to define it.
Well, type adapter is great if you're like, I just want to validate that this data is
a list of integers, for example, as we're seeing on the screen.
Right.
Because let me give people an idea.
Like if you accept, if you've got a JSON, well, just JSON data from wherever, but you
know, a lot of times it's coming over an API or it's provided to you as a file and it's
not your data you control, right?
You're trying to validate it.
You could get a dictionary, a JSON object that's got curly braces with a bunch of stuff,
in which case that's easy to map to a class.
But if you just have JSON, which is bracket, thing, thing, thing, thing, close bracket.
Well, how do you have class that represent the list?
Like it gets really tricky, right?
To be able to understand, you can't model that with classes.
And so you all have this type adapter thing, right?
That's what this, the role plays generally.
Is that right?
Yeah.
And I think it's also really helpful in a testing context.
Like you know, when we want to check that our validation behavior is right for one type,
there's no reason to go like build an entire model if you're really just validating against
one type or structure, type adapter is great.
And so kind of the advice here is you only want to initialize your type adapter object
once.
And the reason behind that is we build a core schema in Python and then attach that to a
class or type adapter, et cetera.
And so if you can, you know, not build that type adapter within your loop, but instead
of instead do it right before or not build it, you know, in your function, but instead
outside of it, then you can avoid building the core schema over and over again.
Yeah.
So basically what you're saying is that the type adapter that you create might as well
be a singleton because it's stateless, right?
Like it doesn't store any data.
It's kind of slightly expensive to create relatively.
And so if you had a function that was called over and over again, and that function had
a loop and inside the loop, you're creating the type adapter, that'd be like worst case
scenario almost, right?
Yeah, exactly.
And I think this kind of goes along with like general best programming tips, right?
Which is like, if you only need to create something once, do that once.
Exactly.
You know, a parallel that maybe goes way, way back in time could be like a compiled
regular expression.
You know, you wouldn't do that over and over in a loop.
You would just create a regular, the compiled regular expression and then use it throughout
your program, right?
Because it's kind of expensive to do that, but it's fast once it's created.
Yeah, exactly.
And funny that you mentioned that.
I actually fixed a bug last week where we were compiling regular expressions twice when
folks like specified that as a constraint on a field.
So definitely just something to keep in mind and easy to fix or implement with type adapters
here.
Yeah, awesome.
Okay.
I like this one.
That's a good one.
Yeah.
So this next tip also kind of goes along with like general best practices, but the more
specific you can be with your type hints, the better.
And so specifically, if you know that you have a list of integers, it's better and more
efficient to specify a type hint as a list of integers instead of a sequence of integers,
for example.
Or if you know you have a dictionary that maps strings to integers, specify that type
hint as a dictionary, not a mapping.
Interesting.
Yeah.
So you could import a sequence from the typing module, just the generic way, but I guess
you probably have specific code that runs that can validate lists more efficiently than
a general iterable type of thing, right?
Yeah, exactly.
So in the case of like a sequence versus a list, it's the like square and rectangle thing,
right?
Like a list is a sequence, but there are lots of other types of sequences.
And so you can imagine for a sequence, we like have to check lots of other things.
Whereas if you know with certainty, this is going to be a list or it should be a list,
then you can have things be more efficient with specificity there.
Does it make any difference at all whether you use the more modern type specifications?
Like traditionally people would say from typing import capital L list, but now you can just
say lowercase L list with the built-in and no import statement.
Are those equivalent or is there some minor difference there?
Do you know?
Yeah, that's a good question.
I wouldn't be surprised if there was a minor difference that was more a consequence of
like Python version, right?
Because there's like, I mean, I suppose you could import the old capital L list in a newer
Python version, but I think the difference is like more related to specificity of a type
in rather than kind of like versioning.
If the use of that capital L list made you write an import statement, I mean, it would
cause the program to start ever so slightly slower because there's another import.
It's got a run where it already knows it's already imported what list is.
You wouldn't believe how many times I get messages on YouTube videos I've done or even
from courses saying, Michael, I don't know what you're doing, but your code is just wrong.
I wrote lowercase L list bracket something and it said list is not a sub indexable or
something like that.
And look, you've just done it wrong.
You're going to need to fix this.
Or you're on Python 3.7 or something super old before these new features are added.
But there's just somewhere in the community we haven't communicated this well.
I don't know.
Yeah, for sure.
I was writing some code earlier today in a meeting and I used the like from typing import
union and then union X and Y type.
My coworker was like, Sydney, use the pipe.
Like what are you doing?
Use the pipe, exactly.
But here's the thing that was introduced in 3.10, I believe.
And if people are in 3.9, that code doesn't run or if they're not familiar with the changes.
So there's all these tradeoffs.
I almost feel like it would be amazing to go back for any time there's a security release
that releases, say another 3.7 or something and change the error message to say this feature
only works in the future version of Python rather than some arbitrary error of you're
doing it wrong.
You know, that would be great.
Yeah, definitely.
Yeah.
Some of those errors can be pretty cryptic with the syntax stuff.
They can.
All right.
So be specific list tuple not sequence if you know it's a list or tuple or whatever.
Yeah.
And then kind of my last minor tip, which great that you brought up import statements
and kind of adding general time to a program is I don't have a slide for this one, but
if we go back to the type adapter slide, we talked about the fact that initializing this
type adapter builds a core schema and attaches it to that class.
And that's kind of done at build time at import time.
So that's like already done.
And if you really don't want to have that import or like build time, take a long time,
you can use the defer build flag.
And so what that does is defers the core schema build until the first validation call.
You can also set that on model config and things like that.
But basically the idea here is like striving to be lazier, right?
Like I see if we don't need to build this core schema right at import time because we
want our program to start up quickly.
That's great.
There's a little bit of a delay on the first validation, but maybe startup time is more
important.
So that's a little bit more of a preferential validation, sorry, preferential performance
tip, but available for folks who need it.
Yeah.
Like, let me give you an example.
I'll give people an example where I think this might be useful.
So in the Talk Python Training, the courses site, I think we've got 20,000 lines of Python
code, which is probably more at this point.
I checked a long time ago, but a lot.
And it's a package.
And so when you import it, it goes and imports all the stuff to like run the whole web app,
but also little utilities like, oh, I just want to get a quick report.
I want to just access this model and then use it on something real quick.
It imports all that stuff.
So that app startup would be potentially slowed down by this.
Where if you know, like only sometimes is that type adapter used, you don't want to
necessarily have it completely created until that function gets called.
So then the first function call might be a little slow, but there'd be plenty of times
where maybe it never gets called.
Right?
Yep, exactly.
Awesome.
Okay.
All right.
So kind of a more complex performance optimization is using tagged unions.
They're still pretty simple.
It's just like a little bit more than a one line change.
So kind of talking about tagged unions, we can go through a basic example, why we're
using tagged unions in the first place, and then some more advanced examples.
This portion of talk Python to me is brought to you by code comments and original podcast
from Red Hat.
You know, when you're working on a project and you leave behind a small comment in the
code, maybe you're hoping to help others learn what isn't clear at first.
Sometimes that code comment tells a story of a challenging journey to the current state
of the project.
Code comments, the podcast features technologists who've been through tough tech transitions,
and they share how their teams survived that journey.
The host Jamie Parker is a Red Hatter and an experienced engineer.
In each episode, Jamie recounts the stories of technologists from across the industry
who've been on a journey implementing new technologies.
I recently listened to an episode about DevOps from the folks at Worldwide Technology.
The hardest challenge turned out to be getting buy in on the new tech stack rather than using
that tech stack directly.
It's a message that we can all relate to.
And I'm sure you can take some hard one lessons back to your own team.
Give code comments a listen.
Search for code comments in your podcast player or just use our link, talkpython.fm/code-comments.
The link is in your podcast player's show notes.
Thank you to code comments and Red Hat for supporting Talk Python to Me.
Let's start with what are tag unions because I honestly have no idea.
I know what unions are, but tagging them, I don't know.
Yeah, sure thing.
So tag unions are a special type of union.
We also call them discriminated unions.
And they help you specify a member of a model that you can use for discrimination in your
validation.
So what that means is if you have two models that are pretty similar, and your field can
be either one of those types of models, model X or model Y, but you know that there's one
tag or like discriminator field that differs, you can specifically validate against that
field and skip some of the other validation, right?
So like, I'll move on to an example here in a second, but basically it helps you validate
more efficiently because you get to skip validation of some fields.
So it's really helpful if you have models that have like 100 fields, but one of them
is really indicative of what type it might be.
I see.
So instead of trying to figure out like, is it all of this stuff, once you know it has
this aspect or that aspect, then you can sort of branch it on a path and just treat it as
one of the elements of the union.
Is that right?
Yes, exactly.
Okay.
So one other note about discriminated unions is you specify this discriminator and it can
either be a string, like literal type or callable type.
And we'll look at some examples of both.
So here's kind of a more concrete example so we can really better understand this.
So let's say we have a, this is the classic example, right?
A cat model and a dog model.
Yeah.
Cat people, dog people.
You're going to start a debate here.
Exactly, exactly.
They both have this pet type field.
So for the cat model, it's a literal that is just the string cat.
And then for the dog model, it's the literal that's the string dog.
So it's just kind of a flag on a model to indicate what type it is.
And you can imagine, you know, in this basic case, we only have a couple of fields attached
to each model, but maybe this is like data in a like vet database.
And so you can imagine like there's going to be tons of fields attached to this, right?
So it'd be pretty helpful to just be able to look at it and say, oh, the pet type is
dog.
So this data is valid for a dog type.
I'll also note we have a lizard in here.
So what this looks like in terms of validation with Pydantic then is that when we specify
this pet field, we just add one extra setting, which says that the discriminator is that
pet type field.
And so then when we pass in data that corresponds to a dog model, Pydantic is smart enough to
say, oh, this is a discriminated union field.
Let me go look for the pet type field on the model and just see what that is and then use
that to inform my decision for what type I should validate against.
OK, that's awesome.
So if we don't set the discriminator keyword value in the field for the union, it'll still
work, right?
It just has to be more exhaustive and slow.
Yeah, exactly.
So it'll still validate and it'll say, hey, let's take this input data and try to validate
it against the cat model.
And then Pydantic will come back and say, oh, that's not a valid cat.
Like let's try the next one.
Whereas with this discriminated pattern, we can skip right to the dog, which you can imagine
helps us skip some of the unnecessary steps.
Yeah, absolutely.
OK, that's really cool.
I had no idea about this.
Yeah, yeah.
It's a cool, I'd say like moderate level feature.
Like I think if you're just starting to use Pydantic, you probably haven't touched discriminated
unions much, but we hope that it's simple enough to implement that most folks can use
it if they're using unions.
Yeah, that's cool.
I don't use unions very often, which is probably why, other than, you know, symptom pipe none,
which is, you know, like optional.
But yeah, if I did, I'll definitely remember this.
Yeah.
All righty.
So as I've mentioned, this helps for more efficient validation.
And then where this really comes and has a lot of value is when you are dealing with
lots of nested models or models that have tons of fields.
So let's say you have a union with like 10 members and each member of the union has 100
fields.
If you could just do validation against 100 fields instead of a thousand, that would be
great in terms of a performance gain.
And then once again, with nested models, you know, if you can skip lots of those union
member validations, also going to boost your performance.
Yeah, for sure.
You know, an example where this seems very likely would be using it with Beanie or some
other document database where the modeling structure is very hierarchical.
You end up with a lot of nested sub-Pydantic models in there.
Yeah, very much so.
So as a little bit of an added benefit, we can talk about kind of this improved error
handling, which is a great way to kind of visualize why the discriminated union pattern
is more efficient.
So right now we're looking at an example of validation against a model that doesn't use
a discriminated union.
And the errors are not very nice to look at.
You basically see the errors for every single permutation of the different values.
And we're using nested models, so it's very hard to interpret.
So we don't have to look at this for too long.
It's not very nice.
But if we look at...
But basically the error message says, look, there's something wrong with the union.
If it was a string, it is missing these things.
If it was this kind of thing, it misses those things.
Like if it was a dog, it misses this.
If it's a cat, it misses that.
And it doesn't specifically tell you.
Exactly.
It's a dog, so it's missing like the collar size or whatever, right?
But then...
And I'll go back and kind of explain the discriminated model for this case in a second.
But if you look at...
This is the model with the discriminated union instead.
We have one very nice error that says, okay, you're trying to validate this X field and
it's the wrong type, right?
So yeah.
The first example that we were looking at was using string type discriminators.
So we just had this pet type thing that said, oh, this is a cat or this is a dog, that sort
of thing.
We also offer some more customization in terms of...
We also allow callable discriminators.
So in this case, this field can be either a string or this instance of discriminated
model.
So it's kind of a recursive pattern, right?
And that's where you can imagine the nested structures becoming very complex very easily.
And we use this kind of callable to differentiate between which model we should validate against.
And then we tag each of the cases.
So a little bit more of a complex application here.
But once again, when you kind of see the benefit in terms of errors and interpreting things
and performance, I think it's generally a worthwhile investment.
That's cool.
So if you wanted something like a composite key equivalent of a discriminator, right?
Like if it has this field and its nested model is of this type, it's one thing versus another.
Like a free user versus a paying user, you might have to look and see their total lifetime
value plus that they're a registered user.
I don't know, something like that.
You could write code that would pull that information out and then discriminate which
thing to validate against, right?
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, definitely comes in handy when you have like...
You're like, okay, well, I still want the performance benefits of a discriminated union,
but I kind of have three fields on each model that are indicative of which one I should
validate against, right?
And it's like, well, you know, taking the time to look at those three fields over the
hundred is definitely worth it.
Just a little bit of complexity for the developer.
One other note here is that discriminated unions are...
Can we go back really quick on the previous one?
So I got a quick question.
So for this, you write a function.
It's given the value that comes in, which could be a string, it could be a dictionary.
Could you do a little bit further performance improvements and add like a func tools, LRU
cache to cache the output?
So every time it sees the same thing, if there's a repeated data through your validation, it
goes, I already know what it is.
What do you think?
Yeah, I do think that would be possible.
That's definitely an optimization we should try out and put in our docs for like the advanced,
advanced performance tips.
Yeah, because if you've got a thousand strings and then you, you know, that were like it's
going to be male, female, male, female, male, male, female, like that kind of where the
data is repeated a bunch.
Then it could just go, yep, we already know that answer.
Yeah.
That'd be potentially, I don't know.
Yeah, no, definitely.
And I will say, I don't know if it takes effect.
I don't think it takes effect with discriminated unions because this logic is kind of in Python,
but I will say we recently added a like string caching setting because we have kind of our
own JSON parsing logic that we use in Pydantic Core.
And so we added a string caching setting so that you don't have to rebuild the exact same
strings every time.
So that's a nice performance piece.
Yeah, nice.
Caching's awesome.
Until it's not.
Yeah, exactly.
So one quick note here is just that discriminated unions are still JSON schema compatible, which
is awesome for the case where you're once again, defining like API requests and responses.
You want to still have valid JSON schema coming out of your models.
Yeah, very cool.
And that might show up in things like open API documentation and stuff like that, right?
Yep, exactly.
So I'll kind of skip over this.
We already touched on the callable discriminators.
And then I'll leave these slides up here as a reference.
Again, I don't think this is worth touching in too much detail, but just kind of another
comment about if you've got nested models, that still works well with discriminated unions.
So we're still on the pet example, but let's say this time you have a white cat and a black
cat model.
And then you also have your existing dog model.
You can still create a union of, you know, your cat union is a union of black cat and
white cat.
And then you can union that with the dogs and it still works.
And once again, you can kind of imagine the exponential blow up that would occur if you
didn't use some sort of discriminator here in terms of errors.
Yeah, very interesting.
OK, cool.
Yeah.
So that's kind of all in terms of my recommendations for discriminated union application.
I would encourage folks who are interested in this to check out our documentation.
It's pretty thorough in that regard.
And I think we also have those links attached to the podcast.
Yeah, definitely.
And then performance improvements in the pipeline.
Is this something that we can control from the outside?
Is this something that you all are just adding for us?
Yeah, good question.
This is hopefully maybe not all in the next version, but just kind of things we're keeping
our eyes on in terms of requested performance improvements and ideas that we have.
I'll go a little bit out of order here.
We've been talking a bunch about core schema and kind of, you know, maybe deferring the
build of that or, you know, just trying to optimize that.
And that actually happens in Python.
So one of the biggest things that we're trying to do is effectively speed up the core schema
building process so that import times are faster and just, you know, Pydantic is more
performant in general.
So one thing that I'd like to ask about, kind of back on the Python side a little bit, suppose
I've got some really large document, right?
Really nested document.
Maybe I've converted some terrible XML thing into JSON or I don't know, something.
And there's a little bit of structured schema that I care about.
And then there's a whole bunch of other stuff that I could potentially create nested models
to go to, but I don't really care about validating them.
It's just whatever it is, it is.
What if you just said that was a dictionary?
Would that short circuit a whole bunch of validation and stuff that would make it faster
potentially?
Yeah.
Turn off the validation for a subset of the model if it's really big and deep and you
don't really care for that part?
Yeah.
Good question.
So there's an annotation called skip validation that you can apply to certain types.
So that's kind of one approach.
I think in the future, it could be nice to offer kind of a config setting so that you
can more easily list features that you want to skip validation for instead of applying
those on a field by field basis.
And then the other thing is if you only define your model in terms of the fields that you
really care about from that very gigantic amount of data, we will just ignore the extra
data that you pass in and pull out the relevant information.
Right.
Okay.
Yeah.
Good.
Back to the pipeline.
Yeah.
So another improvement, we talked a little bit about potential parallelization of things
or vectorization.
One thing that I'm excited to learn more about in the future and that we've started working
on is this thing called SIMD in Jitter.
And that's our JSON iterable parser library that I was talking about.
And so SIMD stands for a single instruction, multiple data.
Basically means that you can do operations faster.
And that's with this kind of vectorization approach.
I certainly don't claim to be an expert in SIMD, but I know that it's improving our validation
speeds in the department of JSON parsing.
So that's something that we're hoping to support for a broader set of architectures going forward.
Yeah, that's really cool.
Just like what Pandas does for Python, instead of looping over and validation and doing something
to each piece, you just go this whole column, multiply it by two.
Yep.
Exactly.
I'm sure it's not implemented the same, but like conceptually the same.
Yep.
Very much so.
And then the other two things in the pipeline that I'm going to mention are kind of related
once again to the avoiding materializing things in Python if we can.
And we're even kind of extending that to avoiding materializing things in Rust if we don't have
to.
So the first thing is when we're parsing JSON in Rust, can we just do the validation as
we kind of chomp through the JSON instead of like materializing the JSON as a Rust object
and then doing all the validation?
It's like, can we just do it in one pass?
Okay.
Is that almost like generators and iterables rather than loading all into memory at once
and then processing it one at a time?
Yeah, exactly.
And it's kind of like, do you build the tree and then walk it three times or do you just
do your operations every time you add something to the tree?
And then the last performance improvement in the pipeline that I'll mention is this
thing called fast model.
Has not been released yet.
Hasn't really even been significantly developed, but this is cool in that it's really approaching
that kind of laziness concept again.
So attributes would remain in Rust after validation until they're requested.
So this is kind of along the lines of the defer build logic that we were talking about
in terms of like, we're not going to send you the data or perform the necessary operations
until they're requested.
Right.
Okay.
Yeah.
If you don't ever access the field, then why process all that stuff, right?
And convert it into Python objects.
Yeah, exactly.
But yeah, we're kind of just excited in general to be looking at lots of performance improvements
on our end, even after the big V2 speed up, still have lots of other things to work on
and improve.
Yeah, it sure seems like it.
And if this free threaded Python thing takes off, who knows, maybe there's even more craziness
with parallel processing of different branches of the model at different, you know, alongside
each other.
Yeah.
So I think this kind of dovetails nicely into like you asked earlier, like, is there a way
that we kind of monitor the performance improvements that we're making?
And we're currently using and getting started with two tools that are really helpful.
And I can share some PRs if that's helpful, send links after.
But one of them is Codspeed, which integrates super nicely with CI and GitHub.
And it basically runs tests tagged with this like benchmark tag.
And then it'll, you know, run them on main compared to on your branch.
And then you can see like, oh, this made my code, you know, 30% slower, like maybe let's
not merge that right away.
Or conversely, if you know there's a 30% improvement on some of your benchmarks, it's really nice
to kind of track and see that.
I see.
So it looks like it sets up.
So this is a Codspeed.io, right?
And then it sets up as a GitHub action as part of your CI/CD.
And you know, probably automatically runs when a PR is open and things along those lines,
right?
Yep, exactly.
All right.
I've never heard of this.
But yeah, if it just does the performance testing for yourself automatically, why not?
Right?
Let it let it do that.
Yeah.
And then I guess another tool that I'll mention while talking about kind of our, you know,
continuous optimization is a one word for it is this tool kind of similarly named called
CodeFlash.
So CodeFlash is a new tool that uses LLMs to kind of read your code and then develop
potentially more performant versions.
Kind of analyze those in terms of, you know, is it pass is this new code passing existing
tests?
Is it passing additional tests that we write?
And then another great thing that it does is open PRs for you with those improvements
and then explain the improvements.
So I think it's a really pioneering tool in the space.
And we're excited to kind of experiment with it more on our PRs and in our repository.
Okay.
I love it.
Just tell me why is this?
Why did this slow down?
Well, here's why.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
And they offer both like local runs of the tool and also built in CI support.
So those are just kind of two tools that we use to use and are increasingly using to help
us kind of check our performance as we continue to develop and really inspire us to, you know,
get those green check marks with the like performance improved on lots of PRs.
The more you can have it where if it passes the automated build, it's just ready to go
and you don't have to worry a little bit and keep testing things and then have uncertainty.
You know that.
It's nice, right?
Because you're allowed to rest and sleep at night.
Yeah, most certainly.
I mean, I said it before, but the number of people who are impacted by Pydantic, I don't
know what that number is, but it has to be tremendous because if there's 400,000 projects
that use it, like think of the users of those projects, right?
Like that, that multiple has got to be big for, you know, I'm sure there's some really
popular ones, for example, FastAPI.
Yeah.
And it's just nice to know that there are other companies and tools out there that can
help us to really boost the performance benefits for all those users, which is great.
All right.
Yeah, that is really cool.
I think, you know, let's talk about one more performance benefit for people and not so
much in how fast your code runs, but in how fast you go from raw data to Pydantic models.
So one thing you probably have seen, we may have even spoken about this before, are you
familiar with JSON to Pydantic?
The website?
Yeah, it's a really cool tool.
Yeah, it's such a cool tool.
And if you've got some really complicated data, like let's see, I'll pull up some weather
data that's in JSON format or something, right?
Like if you just take this and you throw it in here, just don't even have to pretty print
it, it'll just go, okay, well, it looks like what we've got is, you know, this really complicated
nested model here.
And it took, you know, we did this while I was talking, it took 10 seconds for me clicking
the API to get a response to having like a pretty decent representation here.
Yeah, it's great in terms of like developer agility, especially, right?
It's like, oh, I've, you know, heard of this tool called Pydantic.
I've seen it in places like, I don't really know if I want to manually go build all these
models for my super complicated JSON data.
It's like, boom, three seconds done for you, basically.
Exactly.
Like, is it really worth it?
Because I don't want to have to figure this thing out and figure out all the types and
like, no, just paste it in there and see what you get.
You're going to be, it won't be perfect, right?
Some things, if they're null in your data, but they could be something that would make
them an optional element, like they could be an integer or they could be null.
It won't know that it's going to be an integer, right?
Right.
So you kind of got to patch it up a tiny bit, but in general, I think this is really good.
And then also, you know, just drop in with your, your favorite LLM, you know, I've been
using LM studio, which is awesome.
Nice.
I heard you talk about that on one of the most recent podcasts, right?
Yeah.
It's super cool.
You can download, just download LLAMA3 and run it locally with like a, I think my, my
computer can only handle 7 billion parameter models, but you know that you get pretty good
answers and if you give it a JSON, a piece of JSON data and you say, convert that to
Pydantic, you'll get really good results.
You have a little more control over than what you just get with this, this tool.
But I think those two things, while not about runtime performance, you know, going from
I have data till I'm working with Pydantic, that's pretty awesome.
Yeah, definitely.
And if any, you know, passionate open source contributors are listening and want to create
like a CLI tool for doing this locally, I'm sure that would be.
I think this is based on something that I don't use, but I think it's based on this
data model code generator, which I think might be a CLI tool or a library.
Let's see.
Yes.
Oh yeah.
Very nice.
So here, here's the problem that you, you know, you go and define like a YAML file.
You know, like it's, it's just not as easy as like there's a text field I pasted my stuff,
but it does technically, technically work, I suppose.
Yeah.
I know.
Definitely the LLM approach or just the basic website approach is very quick, which is nice.
Yeah.
Let's talk about LLMs just really quick.
Like I feel, you know, you get some of the Python newsletters and other places that like,
here's the cool new packages.
A lot of them are like nine out of 10 of them are about LLMs these days.
I was like, that feels a little over the top to me, but I know there's other things going
on in the world, but you know, just what are your thoughts on LLMs and encoding these days?
I know you, you write a lot of code and think about it a lot and probably use LLM somewhere
in there.
Yeah, no, for sure.
I, I'm pretty optimistic and excited about it.
I think there's a lot of good that can be done and a lot of productivity boosting to
be had from integrating with these tools, both in your like local development environment
and also just in general.
I think sometimes, you know, it's also great in the performance department, right?
Like we can see with CodeFlash using LLMs to help you write for performant code can
also be really useful.
And it's been exciting to see some libraries really leverage Pydantic as well in that space
in terms of like validating LLM outputs or even using LLM calls in Pydantic validators
to validate, you know, data along constraints that are more like language model friendly.
So yeah, I'm optimistic about it.
I still have a lot to learn, but it's cool to see the variety of applications and kind
of where you can plug in Pydantic in that process for fun.
Yeah, I totally agree.
Right now, the context window, like how much you can give it as information than to start
asking questions is still a little bit small.
Like you can't give it some huge program and say, you know, find me the bugs where this
function is called or you know, whatever.
And it like it doesn't quite understand enough all at once.
But that thing keeps growing.
So eventually, someday we'll all see.
Yep.
All right.
Well, let's talk just for a minute, maybe real quick about what you all are doing at
Pydantic the company rather than Pydantic the open source library.
Like what do you all got going on there?
Yeah, sure.
So Pydantic has the company has released our first commercial tool.
It's called LogFire and it's in open beta.
So it's an observability platform.
And we'd really encourage anyone interested to try it out.
It's super easy to get started with, you know, just the basic like pip install of the SDK
and then start using it in your code base.
And then we have the kind of LogFire dashboard where you're going to see the observability
and results.
And so we kind of adopt this like needle in the haystack philosophy where we want this
to be a very easy to use observability platform that offers very like Python centric insights.
And it's this kind of opinionated wrapper around open telemetry, if folks are familiar
with that.
But in kind of the context of performance, one of the great things about this tool is
that it offers this like nested logging and profiling structure for code.
And so it can be really helpful in kind of looking at your code and being like, we don't
know where this performance slowdown is occurring.
But if we integrate with LogFire, we can see that like very easily in the dashboard.
Yeah, you have some interesting approaches, like specifically targeting popular frameworks
like instrument FastAPI or something like that, right?
Yeah, definitely.
Trying to kind of build integrations that work very well with FastAPI, other tools
like that, and even also offering kind of like custom features in the dashboard, right?
Like if you're looking at, you know, if you're using an observability tool, you're probably
advanced enough to want to add some extra things to your dashboard.
And we're working on supporting that with fast UI, which I know you've chatted with
Samuel about as well.
Yeah, absolutely.
I got a chance to talk to Samuel about LogFire and some of the behind the scenes infrastructure
was really interesting.
But also speaking of fast UI, you know, I did speak to him.
When was that?
Back in February.
So this is a really popular project.
And even on the, I was like, quite a few people decided that they were interested in even
watching the video on that one, which, yeah.
Anything with fast UI?
Sorry, did you say anything with fast UI?
Yeah, yeah.
Are you doing anything on the fast UI side?
Are you on the Pydantic side of things?
Yeah, good question.
I've been working mostly on Pydantic, just, you know, larger user base, more feature requests,
but excited to, I've done a little bit on the fast UI side and excited to kind of brush
up on my TypeScript and build that out as a more robust and supported tool.
I think, especially as we grow as a company and have more open source support in general,
that'll be a priority for us, which is exciting.
Yeah.
It's an interesting project.
Definitely a cool way to do JavaScript front ends and react and then plug those back into
Python APIs, like FastAPI and those types of things.
Right.
So, yeah.
Yeah.
And kind of a similarity with fast UI and Logfire, the new tool, is that there's pretty
seamless integration with Pydantic, which is definitely going to be one of the kind
of core tenants of any products or open source things that we're producing in the future.
Yeah.
I can imagine that's something you want to pay special attention to is like, how well
do these things fit together as a whole, rather than just, here's something interesting, here's
something interesting.
Yeah.
Awesome.
All right.
Well, I think that pretty much wraps it up for the time that we have to talk today.
Let's close it out.
Close it out for us with maybe a final call to action for people who are already using
Pydantic and they want it to go faster, or maybe they could adopt some of these tips.
What do you tell them?
Yeah.
So, you know, inform yourself just a little bit about kind of the Pydantic architecture,
just in terms of like, what is core schema and why are we using Rust for validation and
serialization?
And then that can kind of take you to the next steps of, when do I want to build my
core schemas based on kind of the nature of my application?
Is it okay if imports take a little bit longer or do I want to delay that?
And then take a look at discriminated unions.
And then maybe if you're really interested in improving performance across your application
that supports Pydantic and other things, trying out LogFire and just seeing what sort of benefits
you can get there.
Yeah.
See where you're spending your time is one of the very, you know, not just focused on
Pydantic, but in general, our intuition is often pretty bad for where is your code slow
and where is it not slow?
You're like, that looks really complicated.
That must be slow.
Like, nope.
It's that one call to like some sub module that you didn't realize was terrible.
Yeah.
And I guess that kind of circles back to the like LLM tools and, you know, integrated performance
analysis with CodSpeed and CodeFlash and even just other LLM tools, which is like, use the
tools you have at hand.
And yeah, sometimes they're better at performance improvements than you might be, or it can
at least give you good tips that give you, you know, a launching point, which is great.
Yeah, for sure.
Or even good old C profile built right in, right?
If you really, if you want to do it that way.
Awesome.
All right.
Sydney, thank you for being back on the show and sharing all these tips and congratulations
on all the work you and the team are doing.
You know, what a, what a success PyTantic is.
Yeah.
Thank you so much for having me.
It was wonderful to get to have this discussion with you and excited that I got to meet you
in person at PyCon recently.
Yeah, that was really great.
Really great.
Until, until next PyCon.
See you later.
This has been another episode of Talk Python to Me.
Thank you to our sponsors.
Be sure to check out what they're offering.
It really helps support the show.
Take some stress out of your life.
Get notified immediately about errors and performance issues in your web or mobile applications
with Sentry.
Just visit talkpython.fm/sentry and get started for free.
And be sure to use the promo code talkpython, all one word.
Code comments and original podcast from Red Hat.
This podcast covers stories from technologists who've been through tough tech transitions
and share how their teams survived the journey.
Those are available everywhere you listen to your podcasts and at talkpython.fm/code-comments.
Want to level up your Python?
We have one of the largest catalogs of Python video courses over at Talk Python.
Our content ranges from true beginners to deeply advanced topics like memory and async.
And best of all, there's not a subscription in sight.
Check it out for yourself at training.talkpython.fm.
Be sure to subscribe to the show.
Open your favorite podcast app and search for Python.
We should be right at the top.
You can also find the iTunes feed at /iTunes, the Google Play feed at /play, and the Direct
RSS feed at /rss on talkpython.fm.
We're live streaming most of our recordings these days.
If you want to be part of the show and have your comments featured on the air, be sure
to subscribe to our YouTube channel at talkpython.fm/youtube.
This is your host, Michael Kennedy.
Thanks so much for listening.
I really appreciate it.
Now get out there and write some Python code.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[MUSIC ENDS]
[MUSIC]